THROUGH IT AND BEING CURED.
THANK YOU, AMY.
ARTHEL:  OUR NEXT GUEST IS
STRANDED IN ITALY, SHE IS A
STUDENT AT JOHN CABOT UNIVERSITY
IN ROME WHILE HER FAMILY IS IN
MASSACHUSETTS.
FREDERICA, THIS IS THE THIRD
WEEK WE’RE CHECKING IN WITH YOU.
WHEN I FIRST BEGAN TALKING TO
YOU JUST OUT THE GATE YOU HAD A
SMILE ON YOUR FACE.
YOU DON’T HAVE THAT SAME BRIGHT
SMILE RIGHT NOW AND I’M NOT
TRYING TO STEER YOU IN ONE WAY
OR THE OTHER.
I WANT YOUR HONEST OPINION HERE.
TELL US WHAT’S ON YOUR MIND.
WHAT DO YOU WANT TO TELL
EVERYONE WATCHING?
>> I GUESS I’D SAY EVEN THOUGH
THE NUMBER OF DEATHS ARE
CONSTANTLY RISING HERE, IT’S A
PRETTY TRAGIC AND SOMBER
SITUATION HERE, I WOULD JUST SAY
THIS IS A WAKE-UP CALL TO FOLLOW
THE RULES, STAY IN YOUR HOUSE.
IT’S UNFORTUNATELY THAT I HAVE
TO CONSTANTLY SAY THESE THINGS
ON THE NEWS.
I WOULD PREFER TO DO THIS SOME
OTHER WAY.
IT HAS COME TO THIS.
UNFORTUNATELY, THE NUMBERS ARE
GOING DOWN, THAT HASN’T ARRIVED
HERE IN ITALY.
WE RECORDED 800 DEATHS TODAY.
IT’S UNFORTUNATE AND IT’S SAD.
ARTHEL:  IT’S REALLY SAD.
OUR HEARTS ARE OUT WITH ALL THE
PEOPLE IN ITALY AND OF COURSE
YOU, OUR FELLOW AMERICAN.
HOW ARE YOU HOLDING UP?
HOW ARE YOU GETTING FOOD AND
PROVISIONS?
>> WELL, ESSENTIALLY IT’S BEEN A
WEEK SINCE I LEFT MY HOUSE.
I’M PROBABLY NOT GOING TO LEAVE
FOR ANOTHER COUPLE DAYS.
AS FOR THE -- WHAT THEY PUT IN
PLACE, LIKE WE CAN STILL GO TO
THE MARKET AND THE PHARMACY,
LEAVE OUR HOUSE FOR NECESSARY
REASONS BUT APART FROM THAT I
HAVEN’T -- I’M RECEIVING NEWS
THE SAME WAY THE REST OF THE
WORLD IS.
I CAN’T GIVE TOO MANY UPDATES.
I DON’T KNOW MUCH.
I’M STUCK IN HIGH HOUSE.
ARTHEL:  THAT’S A GOOD POINT.
WONDERING IF YOU YOU’VE GOT A
SENSE, I DON’T KNOW MAYBE
E-MAILING, IF YOU HAVE FRIENDS
THERE.
YOU’RE A SENIOR, YOU’RE A SENIOR
AT JOHN CABOT UNIVERSITY IN ROME
WHICH MEANS YOU ARE OF A CERTAIN
AGE THAT AT FIRST IT WAS THOUGHT
THAT YOU WERE NOT AS VULNERABLE
TO THE CORONAVIRUS.
YOUR AGE GROUP.
AND NOW THERE’S A NEW STUDY
SAYING YOUR I THINK GROUP IS.
WHAT IS IT THAT YOU WOULD LIKE
TO DIRECTLY SAY TO SOME OF YOUR
FELLOW MILLENNIALS BECAUSE IT’S
PROBABLY BETTER HEARING IT FROM
YOU THAN ME.
>> I WOULD JUST SAY TO TAKE ME
AS AN EXAMPLE, A COUPLE WEEKS
AGO I THOUGHT THE IMPOSSIBLE
WOULD HAVE NEVER HAND AND THEN
IT HAPPENED.
SO BE SAFE, BE SMART.
MAKE SMART DECISIONS.
START STAYING IN YOUR HOUSE,
SPEND TIME WITH YOUR FAMILY
DURING THIS TIME, THAT’S REALLY
IMPORTANT.
I CAN’T.
SO I’M -- WE’RE KIND OF ALL IN
THE SAME BOAT IN ITALY, ALL
STUDENTS THAT HAVE REMAINED.
WE’RE TRYING TO BE GRATEFUL AND
LEARN THE BIGGER LESSON OF ALL
OF THIS.
THERE WILL BE A BIGGER LESSON.
I THINK THAT AMERICA CAN TAKE
THE LESSON THAT WE ARE
EXPERIENCING HERE IN ITALY.
IT WILL BE REALLY HELPFUL TO
FIGURE OUT THE PATH THAT THIS
WILL GO ON AND IF WE CAN STOP IT
POTENTIALLY.
ARTHEL:  AND AS I SAID, YOUR
FAMILY IS IN MASSACHUSETTS.
I’M SURE YOU’RE ABLE TO FACETIME
WITH THEM OR E-MAIL WITH THEM.
WHAT ARE YOU SAYING TO THEM?
I’M SURE THEY’RE CONCERNED ABOUT
YOU.
WHAT ARE YOU TELLING THEM?
>> THEY’RE CONCERNED.
WE’RE TAKING IT LIKE A DAY BY
DAY SITUATION.
MY MOM IS MORE UPDATED THAN
ANYBODY ELSE I KNOW PROBABLY ON
THE CORONAVIRUS.
SHE SENDS ME CONSTANTLY THE
DAILY STATISTICS OF IT ALL.
SHE KEEPS ME UPDATED.
I’M REALLY GRATEFUL FOR THAT AS
WELL.
BUT WE’RE TAKING IT DAY BY DAY,
LIKE I SAID.
WE’RE NOT SURE WHEN I’LL BE
HOME.
I’M NOT TOO UP-TO-DATE ON WHAT
THE TRAVEL RESTRICTIONS ARE
CURRENTLY SO I’M NOT SURE BUT I
WAS LOOKING AT PRICE OF TICKETS,
THEY’RE ABOUT $2,000.
IT’S NOT ABOUT THE PRICE, IT’S
MORE ABOUT THE RISK AND WE’RE
GOING TO WAIT IT OUT.
BUT THEY MISS ME AND I MISS
THEM.
ARTHEL:  WELL, YOU STAY SAFE AND
YOU STAY HEALTHY AND MAYBE I’LL
GET A CHANCE TO TALK TO YOU
AGAIN NEXT WEEK.
I REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR TIME,
SPENDING THE TIME WITH US,